foreign
[Music]
coming up on FYI lioness footballer Beth
Mead gives us her advice on getting into
sport
[Music]
the world have died we cover the great
big dinosaur
[Applause]
places
hello this is your Weekly News show FYI
where we give you the latest info and
you get to report on your own stories
yep and we're going to start with all
the trouble that's been happening in
cities across France yeah there have
been many protests because of the death
of a 17 year old boy called nael he was
shot by police after he was stopped in a
car he was driving in Paris police
officers claimed the shooting was in
self-defense as officers lives were in
danger but a video emerged off the
incident that showed us that wasn't true
his desk bought a lot of anger and a
series of protests that started in Paris
students read to other cities
properties were damaged cars were set on
fire and thousands of people were
arrested Lionel's family have now called
for peace and an end to the protests
saying violence does not honor nil's
memory
French president Emmanuel macron said
nothing justifies the death of a young
person and also called for calm in all
the news that has been hit in the
headlines some of our teachers in
England have been going on strike again
they're members of England's biggest
teaching Union the National Education
Union and they refused to go to work for
two days it meant that many of us
weren't able to go to school yeah it's
all to do with how much money teachers
in England are being paid some of them
say that with the cost of things like
food and fuel going up they need to be
paid more so they can still afford these
sorts of things after previous strike
action in February the government
offered teachers a new pay deal however
the unions involved in the dispute have
rejected the offer as schools will have
to make Cuts elsewhere to be able to
afford it
thank you
so you guys know I love to dance right
yeah man you've got the moves haven't
you you're a great dancer well I was
recently in my element as I got to check
out a big national dance competition and
let's just say
it's giving me some inspiration
get behind me is where all the magic is
going on it's the grand finale of the
great big dance off it's the biggest
national dance competition for the
schools in England and Wales let's see
what's going on
[Music]
I'm gonna go find a group to chat with
see how they're feeling and hopefully
they can teach me a room or two gastro's
Community Primary School gloucestershire
are taking their inspiration from
Ghostbusters so what am I learning
[Music]
three two one go
oh that's really good
so can you tell me what do you think
being able to dance means to you I feel
really happy and excited because
whenever I dance I feel like there's a
new move being created what do you guys
think of the other groups I mean do you
guys think you have some Fierce
competition it'll be really hard to at
least come top free in this competition
because of how great all the other
dancers are
I supported a team that I want to learn
some moves from Sogo All Saints primary
school in Chester are already three
times winners of this competition
foreign
[Music]
what do you guys think of the other
groups there's one or two that me and my
friend Ollie were talking about and they
were like wow they're really good so
um yeah I think the competition will be
first but let's hope to win how do you
feel when you're dancing oh
I think it's my favorite thing to do
[Music]
but I just feel brilliant when I'm
dancing it's really exhilarating and I
just love the feeling
the competition is hotting up and it's
clear that each of these groups have
worked so hard in their routines we're
here before the judges announcer results
it's a pretty nerve-wracking moment but
I'm here with sorghor or Saint schools
to ask them a few questions so how are
you guys feeling my heart's beating like
really fast and my chest is just like
turning over so many times I think the
judges might give another school an
opportunity but it would still be
amazing if we get police first second or
third but now the moment everyone in
this room has been waiting for has
arrived there
what's the winners oh who's gonna be
first
appears to be so good also
[Applause]
let's go
Circle oh since Primary School have just
got first what a moment four times in a
row now four times in a row I repeat
four times in a row so Google says
Primary School what a school great
dancers great people oh wow
how you guys all not feeling
well what are you guys gonna do to
celebrate
hi
[Music]
would you drink this water scientists on
the International Space Station have
developed a new way of making drinking
water using the astronaut sweat and
urine oh that is horrible well
apparently the end recycled water is
even cleaner than the drinking water we
get from our Taps on Earth how cool is
that
now if you're a football fan like me
then you'll know that the Women's World
Cup kicks off in just a few weeks in
Australia and New Zealand now
unfortunately England are missing a few
players including forward Beth Mead but
she's still been very busy off the pitch
right in a new book called raw and she
joins us now hi Beth thanks for joining
us thanks for having me so is your book
almost like a guidebook to following
your dreams and then getting into the
sport that you love so I think the book
can be literally what anyone wants it to
be I want anyone to find the love and
passion for spa I don't want to be too
serious but I also wanted to give the
reality of becoming a professional
sports person so when someone obviously
delves in to wanting to go down that
path which I hope lots of people do
um you know it helps them and guides
them so obviously playing at the highest
level what do you say is your biggest
life lesson
people don't see the whole picture they
see 90 minutes on a football pitch they
don't see every single day and every
hurdle you have to you know jump over or
a bad day or a good day they don't
always see them aspects of it so I think
it was important for me to share that in
that in that aspect because it's not all
smooth sailing and that's okay
everybody's journey is different but
that's what makes it exciting and it
makes it all worthwhile that you've had
a journey now what advice would you give
to some boys and girls who maybe feel a
bit intimidated or a bit nervous about
starting and joining a new team
um the best advice I've always been
given is regardless of what I'm doing
whether it's football whether it's off a
pitch whether it's talking to a group of
people in front of them my mum always
told me to take one step at a time and
as simple as it sounds
it's so true like when I first came to
Arsenal I was injured I struggled
she was like you know get up out of bed
in the morning go make your breakfast
that's one girl done and although it's a
normal thing to do within the day it was
like right I've done that now take that
off now I get in my car and I've got a
training and then I'll do this and I was
taking each step at a time so I would
say for like people wanting to obviously
go into a new spa or football whatever
it may be is do your process each thing
that you do you take off it's a girl
done go and enjoy it and have some fun
well thank you so much for joining us no
thank you thanks for having me
the summer holidays are nearly here
which means there are loads of great
family films coming out to enjoy in the
cinema and when that caught her eye was
the new Disney Pixar Animation Elemental
and I'm really jealous that FYI News
Club member Chloe got to meet and have a
chat with the cast
Elemental is all about Ember she lives
in Elemental City where she's
discouraged by her immigrant parents
from mixing with other elements
especially water why doesn't anyone get
to tell you what you can do in your life
come on
what made you audition for your role we
actually got a a very rare call it's
like hey this director wants to meet
with you and
um I hopped on with Peter our director
and he started with his story and what
this story kind of means to him I grew
up in a grocery store and my father and
mother were immigrants now when I was a
kid I just wanted to fit in America and
so I pushed some of that away of that
culture and then as I grew up I began to
appreciate it more I've been trying to
fill my father's shoes another reason I
absolutely loved this film is because my
parents are immigrants what advice would
you give to someone who is new to this
country or America wow I'm also an
immigrant in my country of uh the United
States I became a citizen while we were
making this movie actually family is
important
I think being aware and available to
everything that you're learning in this
new space
and also finding ways to connect to home
as well those values those Traditions I
think I wouldn't I wouldn't be who I am
without my parents instilling those in
me but we
simple rule
elements cannot mix
one of the themes that I noticed in the
film was an intolerance of those who are
different and it reminds me a lot of
anti-immigration what would you say to
the people who are anti-immigrants we
all deserve love respect and we all have
you know families and friends and and
full lives and dreams to accomplish so
it's those similarities I really feel
like that they could look at yeah
there's so much waste and missed
opportunity
hating and feeling those kinds of
feelings how has this movie affected you
guys it really helped me out it just
came at the right time I was buoyed by
this project by the people process of it
and then seeing it and then sharing it
with my family this made me happy
this made me really happy too
[Music]
Chloe thank you so much for reporting
for us so I'm wondering what was it like
interviewing the actors it was really
good it was really fun and the thing is
they were all so nice I absolutely loved
it it was just a really nice experience
and it was like knowing the behind the
scenes of the film and it was just
amazing yeah it must have been awesome
like watching the film and then actually
being able to meet the people in the
film so what do you think is the main
message that the movie gives off
probably that to never judge someone and
I another reason why I love this film is
because it relates so much to what's
going on nowadays because me personally
my parents are from Albania and they're
immigrants a bit like Ember and her
family and it gives off the message to
always remember to be kind to people who
are new and not only that like racism as
well because not to always be kind to
everyone and it just gives off such a
nice message I mean it's amazing when
you know a film can be entertaining but
also send out a strong message and teach
you something thank you so much for
reporting for us Chloe thank you for
having me here
if you have a story and want to report
on FYI get in touch via our webpage or
even better get your teacher to set up
an FYI News Club at your school members
get the chance to report for us we'll
even help you film Your Own Story you
can watch and discuss the latest
episodes with free resources every week
so 13 year old roll Street in
skateboarder Arista true has become the
first female to land the 720
it's a trick which involves making two
full rotations in the air awesome
foreign
Motorsports then we've got some exciting
news for you yep on the 23rd of July
it's the Formula One Hungarian Grand
Prix and FYI is taking over some of the
coverage on Sky Sports
get ready for heart pounding action the
Roar of the engines and a dramatic race
to reach the check of flag
on and I are heading to Hungary to
experience for ourselves the thrill of
Formula One and joining us out there
we've got a friend who's a real grand
prix expert
hi there I'm Zach and ever since I was
seven years old I've absolutely loved
Formula One now here's the exciting bit
the three of us are not only going to be
watching the race we're also going to be
commentating on it yep Sky Sports are
letting us loose behind the scenes and
you know what I reckon we're going to
bring something really fresh and new to
the coverage right definitely I've got
so many questions I want to ask the
drivers and I just can't wait to get a
sense of how tense it can be in the pit
Lane
and we'll be reporting back to FYI the
following week to let you know we got on
it's going to be epic honestly
well that's nearly it for this week but
don't forget you can catch up on all our
episodes of FYI on our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI but before
we go we'd just like to wish the
National Health Service a happy 75th
birthday the NHS treats over a million
people a day and has made a difference
to the lives of countless Children and
Families
[Applause]
I'm hugely grateful for the NHS firstly
they saved my Dad's life two years ago
after having a stroke and secondly I
wouldn't be able to run walk and do
sports like I can't today if it wasn't
for the NHS this is my favorite nurse
Danny and then this is the man who
chopped my leg off
time
so thank you
[Music]
NHS because they've been with my family
for so many generations and now we're
going to introduce another generation
because I'm having a baby sister
foreign
[Music]
for fixing my broken collarbone even
though my dad said there was nothing up
with it I'm grateful to the NHS because
a couple years ago when my sister broke
her foot they really helped her out and
they really helped take our mind off the
fact that her foot was broken three
method tassels
I would like to thank the NHS for
continuing to work throughout lockdown
and saving so many lives thank you NHS
from all the Boston FYI we'll see you
next time bye
foreign